hey there are you confused male and or
female contemplating your life choices
will to live and most importantly which
anime you'll be watching the season of
course you are what am I saying
well the summer's over now so I'm sorry
you can get that town you want it or had
your summer love of Sally big tips but
don't worry not everything's bad the
full season of anime is started so what
better way to drown your sorrows and
with the landslide of new Asian cartoons
coming out don't worry these guys will
never betray you now I know you're
feeling optimistic because anything can
be good but you know better than that so
here's the deal I've watched a bunch of
first episodes and from my impressions
I'd either commit to watching it give it
3 episodes to the side or just drop it
on the spot so you can see for yourself
if anything takes your fancy
now you may already know what you want
to watch maybe you like action or cute
girls or something with tits note to
self
use this as an excuse but tits in the
thumbnail but this is the perfect time
to sample something you normally
wouldn't who knows maybe you'll find
something that will surprise you or
probably not alright blood eyeballs or
bloody bores or bloody wars may right
off the bat I have to ask who the [ __ ]
did you let design this logo this logo
looks like it was made in 2009 by some
edgy teenager who post Call of Duty
montages on YouTube but who knows I
can't just rag on an anime for its logo
so let's see how the anime actually is
Chung tear shard and flaming tell me
quick this this isn't Japanese are you
[ __ ] kidding right now China China
China we anime now okay look the whole
Chinese cartoon jokes are getting a bit
old now so we need a new catchy name for
anime coming out of China like China
mayshen or chana Mei or animated
pictures originating from the People's
Republic of China possibly including the
regions of Hong Kong and Taiwan there
may regardless of where this came from
though it wasn't really that good dear
mother today I saw which pilot a flying
machine got in order to save a falling
princess from Nazis I'm not sure why it
happened but it did dear son go to
[ __ ] rehab already so is Etta
definitely looks like it has potential
it's set in an alternate historical
timeline where there are witches who fly
around on [ __ ] machine guns where the
country of Germania is at war with the
country of Britannia hashtag ho Kia
three who confirms let's not forget the
enemy has a character called princess
fine
ninis princess fine goose a doggie
whoops cushy yeah you got that right
cause she's princess far so yeah I don't
really know what I watched but it looks
pretty and it had cute girls who may or
may not be lesbian so it's probably
gonna make a lot of money so yeah I
don't really know what I watched but it
looks pretty and it had cute girls who
may or may not be lesbian so it's
probably gonna make a lot of money so
yeah I don't really know what I watch
but it looks pretty and it had cute
girls who made is pop quiz for you
you're an enemy commander and there's
one person standing in your way he's
half-dead cuz you've been paired him
with three [ __ ] Spears to the stomach
so do you a finish him off cuz just
[ __ ] look at him be or do you meant
to charge and trample him because he can
hardly stand anyway or see run away like
a [ __ ] [ __ ] is always dead yes we have
drifters from the creator of Helsing and
I'm not yet sure this anime is going to
be about but it looks as stupidly fun as
Helsing was I mean we have some kind of
alternate dimension war that's being
fought by famous historical figures such
as Nobunaga yes that Nobunaga now if
you're not so quizzed up on your
Japanese history the important thing
that you need to know about Nobunaga is
that he's apparently the only historical
Japanese figure who's allowed to appear
in anime ever meanwhile at a1 pictures
all right people
the fall season starts next week so we
really got to make an impact with this
first episode what do we spend our
animation budget on well I had some
pretty cool ideas about some flashy
scenes that could really show off the
talent and know-how behind this
production without having to appeal to
the lowest common denominator I agree
with Ted let's animate some tips what
that's literally the complete opposite
of what Isis
turd you've done it again I don't know
why even [ __ ] bother anymore so a
cold night happened and it was certainly
an anime I mean it had animation it had
music it had characters with dialogue
and it even had an opening theme but as
you may be able to tell I'm having a
hard time forming an opinion of it
because I had no idea what the [ __ ] was
going on I mean that's not always a bad
thing I'm a smart guy shut up there have
been absolutely great anime that have
started off confusing the audience but
with about a million things happening at
once the only vibes I got from this
first episode was that Monika tree and
Rara had a persona for themes baby
diagnosed with ADHD oh hey there I see I
see that will going for another bloody
dark take on the magical girl genre
that's ok I mean at least you warned us
in the first 50 seconds this time where
i read oka but I've got to ask your
premise sounds a hell of a lot like
Battle Royale with magical girls so are
you going for an entertaining edgy kind
of show or a totally serious
deconstruction of magical girls because
that's already been done pretty well
where I read ocher and if you are was it
really necessary to make one of your
magical girls look like a five dollar
hooker
hi my name's Chloe that's right the C in
the L are silent regardless though you
have piqued my interest so I'll give you
a chance all else was good it's a sports
anime with everything you'd want from a
Sports anime except this time it's rugby
but at the end of the day does it really
matter what sport it is as long as you
have great matches SEM PI's he'll be
graduating next year and a main duo who
may or may not be bombing each other in
the shower
normally right now I'd be like yo e
overtones in the sports anime is the sky
also blue but you know I can kind of
understand it in a sport where you get
to see a group of big sweaty men pile on
each other in an attempt to see you can
glump each other the hardest but then
again the thing about rugby is that it's
like the jojo's of sports you watch some
of the stuff they do and you just think
isn't this like a bit camp like I'm not
the only one thinking this right and
then you see the people involved and
you're just like [ __ ] okay these guys
are manlier than anything I could ever
hope to be but if you want to see more
scenes of guys who are really good at
funneling with balls
also possibly being really good at
funneling with balls haikyuu there's
another season I mean I don't have as
much say about this because if you've
already watched the first two seasons
you're probably watching this as well
but hey good sports anime and speaking
of sequels hey look it's that
nondistinct second season to that show
people are probably watching but I
haven't seen the first season yet
cool I'm really sure that this is
actually a continuation to the first
season that people are gonna watch okay
let's shop everything for a moment I
just want to be serious with you all for
a second
I think anime can be a truly amazing
medium it's one of the final vanguards
of 2d animation in the world and the
whole platform allows artists to tell
stories in ways that could never be
expressed in any other medium and every
so often there comes the show which
completely flips the medium on its head
and redefines what anime is capable of
Keijo is not one of these anime but
anime still definitely need them now I
don't know who's sick perverted
degenerate genius modern Einstein of our
time had the idea of making a sports
anime where girls wrestle each other off
with their asses but it's so stupid and
self-aware that as a simple ass man with
the most refined of tastes it was
actually entertaining even if it did
cost me a few brain cells watching them
on TV notice it's gone full circle
people though I don't know why any anime
would need eight [ __ ] exclamation
points at the end of its title though
it's almost as if Keijo saw the amounts
of exclamation points in the names of
the different anime of the season and
was like and this yes to go even further
beyond
in conclusion [ __ ] the OPI defenders
will my fellow booty warriors please
stand up so right off the bat I'm
backing March comes like a line as the
Dark Horse of the season because it has
the most atmospheric and best directed
opening episode of this entire season
and yet no one seems to be talking about
it it's opening sequence completely drew
me in and it didn't need amazing soccer
sequences or a bloke taking 10,000
Spears in his knob or half-naked girl
smashing each other's arses in their
faces all it needed was a beautiful
soundtrack great cinematography and just
a masterclass in visual storytelling
just don't come into this expecting it
to be all smiles and rainbows I mean
every characters default emotion
basically looks like the frowny face
emoji this week in anime Yuri on ice
next week in anime yaoi on fire oh god
everything [ __ ] bird look I'm not
gonna lie this anime is gay yay like
free had sex with a flamboyant Elton
John with Chang in the background
shouting gay kind of gay but no amount
of bare ass homoerotic tension or
full-on present male nipple could make
me lose the massive erection I got from
the [ __ ] animation of the ice-skating
scenes in this show I mean just look at
it oh god it looks so [ __ ] beautiful
and this opening this [ __ ] opening I
don't care if you're straighter than a
honeymoon dick and the implication of
male or male action makes you vomit when
there are scenes this beautifully
animated and directed I don't get to say
this often but grow a pair [ __ ]
ovaries and just watch it already
hey guys Giga Kia hope you enjoyed the
video thank you very much this month -
Lau Ken and everyone else on patreon for
supporting me this month you'd also like
to help this channel to make videos like
this possible go to patreon accomplished
here if you enjoyed this video and you'd
like to see my previous seasonal chart
video sure you click on the links here I
know what's the thing that you'll be
glad to know the long awaited next
episode of anime minutes is in the
editing stage and will be done sometime
near the end of this month that's pretty
much it you can also follow me on
Facebook and Twitter but so far from
nuts
I've been get up and I'll see you all
next
Ted you've done it Oh Ted done what well
hey you doing this to me Ted Ted give me
the lighter dad totally give me like
content all right we could have little
chance just don't leave the company